this is gallium it's one of the elements
of the periodic table which is this
thing here and if you're not a scientist
you probably only know this as a chart
you're supposed to memorize in high
school but what if instead of being a
boring chart well it was something that
you could touch and feel that's what
we're going to try to do today but is it
even possible well I'm not sure yet hey
uh we're doing a video about the
periodic table of the elements yeah I'm
asking people how many of them they
think we can find high 70s maybe 20 to
30 but I'm optimistic I'm hoping for a
lot more ballpark 20. there's 118 in
total right and I'm gonna get 118. well
you can collect all of them no
at what point would your periodic table
start killing you exposure to toxic
smoke would have already killed you
would be like a nuclear bomb exploding
over and over again I kind of remember
it's been a long time but Bill Gates has
the entire collection in his office why
can't I so why don't you just go to
Christina get a budget from her let's
motivate you a little bit so I don't
think you're gonna collect too many but
let's say you can collect 80. if you
collect under 80 elements yeah or if you
go over budget yeah how about you eat
cheese and eggs
here's the thing I don't eat cheese or
eggs I don't but I don't really are you
gonna eat the sandwich or not if I don't
get 80 elements I'll eat a egg and
cheese sandwich or if you go over budget
I'm not gonna go over budgets did you
deal
despite the fact that everyone I spoke
to thought it was going to be impossible
I still wanted to figure out if there
was a way we could do this so I went to
talk to a chemistry expert for some
advice it was pretty impossible to make
your own periodic table at home without
specialized equipment and I don't
advertise it
um okay well is there any way to create
it with everyday items maybe if you
tried you could majority of elements you
would probably collect them if not in
pure form then then in some kind of
mixture but that was all I needed to
hear so with 500 bucks in my pocket okay
do you go for it and the determination
not to eat an egg sandwich it's like
spongy it's like a chewing a rubber band
it was time to get to work to build our
periodic table we're going to go row by
row I expect the later elements of the
periodic table will be a lot harder and
more expensive to find but we don't have
to worry about that for right now the
earlier things are going to be a little
bit cheaper easier to find or borrow
from someone and that's going to save us
a lot of money first throw is easy
hydrogen is found in pretty much every
living thing including plants
foreign
can be found in balloons luckily it's
cheap it also makes you talk funny
now we're on to a row with some solids
and again these are pretty cheap and
easy and can be found around the office
my house or just outside things like
lithium beryllium and Boron can all be
found in things like batteries bikes and
eye drops the bike we're going to borrow
from a friend of mine
as for things like carbon and oxygen
well those things are everywhere like
without them we'd all be dead so this is
going to cross those off the list
nitrogen is in our soil
chlorine is in our toothpaste and this
neon sign here has well you guessed it
neon in it but it took up a huge chunk
of our budget now we were on to row
three and by this time I gotta say I was
feeling really good about this it was
super easy we managed to get all the
things on our list so far and we stayed
on budget this is for the haters and the
ones who doubted me what are you doing
okay yeah no that's fair that's fair
we'll buy you it's coming out of the
budget though
foreign
trip to the grocery store turns out a
lot of the items on this row are things
we can find in different kinds of food I
did some reading earlier about periodic
table and I think now is about the time
we should talk a little bit more about
it and tell you what it's all about the
periodic table was developed as a map
for scientists to help them understand
what the elements do and what they're
for it didn't start like this either it
looked like this at one point and then
this there's even other versions that
don't look like a table but more like a
globe and they wrap around but this one
the one that's popular now was invented
by a guy named Dimitri Mendeleev in 1869
and Mendeleev didn't just list the
elements or put them in groups that had
all been done before mendeleev's
contributions came from being able to
find elements that previously didn't
exist weird I know but stick with me
here he figured to arrange the table
periodically but as he was doing that
the notice gaps in the table
well that's because of the time only 60
elements were considered for the
periodic tables based on mendeleev's
table he knew there'd be over 100
elements after he took into account all
the atomic weights looking at the
chemical and physical properties of the
elements next to his gaps Mendeleev was
able to predict which elements would
exist in the future and his predictions
were spot on he predicted gallium right
down to its atomic weight and properties
and over the next 20 years he predicted
the existence of other elements like
Scandium and germanium those were
discovered after he died so I guess I've
got Mendeleev to thank for this
scavenger hunt and for that egg and
cheese sandwich if I lose
oh and by the way we got all the stuff
we needed for row four it was a bit
expensive as groceries are these days
but we managed to stay on budget
somehow we also managed to find arsenic
now I always thought this was strictly a
poison but apparently it's in mushrooms
although not in the quantity enough to
poison someone
I hope
[Music]
it's too bad that's tasty stuff okay now
we were under row five we were able to
get a couple of these elements but as we
went on they were increasingly rare and
hard to find like the element xenon
which is found in cameras
or tellurium this element is found
mostly in fridges
but then we ran into some issues okay
I'm seeing here antimony is found mostly
in bullets well we're in Canada so
that's not likely going to happen and
technetium looks to only really be used
in x-ray machines you need to go for an
x-ray anytime soon
yeah well that's also out of the budget
so we were able to get a couple of these
elements but there were a bunch others
that were Way Out Of Reach they were
either too hard to find or way too
expensive
yeah
now we were on to row six and here's
where things started to get tricky we
have some old favorites on here like
gold lead and Mercury those were easy to
get some of the elements we had to
borrow others we had to buy but they
were getting more and more expensive and
then we started to get to the rare earth
metals not only are these Metals rare
but they're also really difficult to
extract and because of that they're only
used in certain Real World products like
thulium is really only used in laser
surgery and again that's out of our
budget but we were still able to get a
couple of these things like europium and
televisions and tourbillum in
fluorescent lamps
okay we're starting to approach the end
of row six and things were starting to
get a little weird we've covered the
solids liquids gases but now we were
starting to get into radioactive
materials and those are stupidly
expensive and not to mention downright
impossible to find take astatine for
example scientists say at Max there's
only 25 grams of it on Earth at any one
given time and even if you were able to
find it it would decay in less than a
day
and the weirdness didn't stop there onto
row seven we were really only able to
get one of these elements it was radium
which is found in some watches
and the rest are pretty much exclusive
to nuclear reactors or stuff we just
can't get a hold of and then there are
these elements here these things are
really really strange they barely exist
and they're only used for research
purposes their use if any is unknown and
some of them have only existed in the
form of a couple of atoms for barely a
second
and with the periodic table now complete
it's time to see how many items I've
managed to collect
let's hope it's 80.
Okay Marina I think I'm ready I got it
all okay I don't think it looks like 80
to me here do you think you got any one
two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
twenty one twenty two twenty three
twenty four five six seven eight nine
thirty okay it's Thirty okay we're at
forty forty one
we'll see
well technician we just can't get it 61
63 yeah that's lead are you sure about
this yeah it's a representation of lead
of course nuts would never be made of
lead because their lead is pliable and
that wouldn't work for nuts four
65.
would you get this one in 66
yeah I only see 66. you know what that
means
egg sandwich but
um we stayed completely under budget we
could probably uh
since I saved some money maybe I'll I
could slide it to you and you could keep
it and I wouldn't need an extra sandwich
no no no no we agreed that 80 and you
stay under budget I got a nasty teen and
a tennis team
yes I have two more oh okay so okay 68
sure uh no but you're gonna bring them
on the table
[Music]
okay these are halogen lamps that go uh
after shooting TV camera lights it has
one 67. yeah okay
shout it loud and proud
68. you're still missing 12.
so what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do about it you're gonna eat a
cheese sandwich that's what you're gonna
do
let's open it up
it has egg and it has teeth
it's not looking good for me
okay I'm not looking forward I'm not
looking more I brought along a bucket
here
because I'm probably gonna
Chuck my guts out
but it turns out it's pretty much
impossible to collect an exact copy of
the periodic table and that's because a
lot of these ones in the bottom line the
actinoids are radioactive and a lot of
these in the 100 row are used for
research purposes only so even that
bookcase full of periodic table elements
that Bill Gates has in his office those
are probably just representations in the
same way that we use these nuts to
represent lead he doesn't have all those
radioactive materials in his office it
would probably be illegal so we really
shouldn't feel too bad because we came
up with 68 out of the 118 elements on
the periodic table and we came in way
under budget so there's a good chance
that I don't have to eat that egg
sandwich anyway
so before you uh watch me suffer here
the least you could do is press like And
subscribe there we're trying to get to
10 million followers this year and
that'll help us be able to do a lot more
things like this putting together the
periodic table uh some bigger ideas on
what if this year you really want me to
do it right I mean every people live
through this right like it's not the end
of the world it's not poison here we go
or
it's like spongy it's like a chewing a
rubber band
[Music]
with with her heels that was all real
so it's probably for the best that we
are not able to recreate uh the periodic
table because we'd be met with a lot of
explosions I'd be dead and we'd likely
set off a nuke this experiment didn't
work out quite the best for us and I did
this experiment but let us know in the
comments what you think we should do
next and hopefully it doesn't have
anything to do with disgusting Foods or
swallowing something maybe make it a
little bit easier on me please but
that's a story
for another
what if hey whatevers thanks very much
for making it all the way to the end of
the video I want to give you a chance to
win the shirt that I wore in the video
well not this exact shirt but one that's
clean and one that's in your size I also
want to give you a chance of getting a
zoom call with myself and the what if
crew all you have to do is leave us a
comment tell us what you think we should
do for our next in real life video best
one wins
[Music]